à présent Michell à la rencontre d'une
chaîne pas comme les autres oui elle
s'appelle squeeze et elle a intégré
l'équipe de l'unité de soins palliatif
de l'hôpital de Blois depuis quelques
mois maintenant là-bas elle apporte
sourire et tendresse à des patients
souffrant de maladie grave hélè Chapel
allez je vais aller chercher
squee coucou ma squeette ça va ça
va depuis le mois de juin
S de Blois dans cette unité de soins
palliatif cette labrador a pour mission
d'apporter un peu de chaleur et de
réconfort au patients et à leurs proches
ce Maala elle rend visite à François
Xavier 40 ans naturellement la chienne
monte se coucher à ses côtés un moment
de douceur pendant lequel la maladie
s'éloigne il n'y a alors plus de
soignant ni de soigner juste deux
humains et un chien on parle des animaux
on parle de la famille de sa de sa
petite fille du coup bah qui pourah qui
qui a un Squeeze est quand même un lien
très important donc du coup B on échange
sur les choses de la vie et on
communique aut que que la
maladie selon François Xavier squee est
une allié de taille quand elle est là
elle rend la visite à l'hôpital moins
traumatisante pour sa fille de 3 ans
pere aujourd'hui pour elle c'est une
joie de voir ce cuise et donc ça change
complètement le rapport à l'hôpital bah
c'est vrai que quand en fin de journée
on a vu squise la petite était contente
que bah ça Fass tout le reste parce
qu'on est content n nous-même on est on
est relaxé après squeeze a été formé à
l'accompagnement social par
l'association andichien tous les jours
elle vient au travail en même temps que
Dalila l'une de ses deux référentes
hébergeantes mais dès qu'elle n'a plus
sa cap sur le dos Squeeze est une
chienne comme les autres le son son
entre guillemets son planning ça va être
de beaucoup se reposer déjà d'avoir des
temps des temps de repos ça va dépendre
des patients des besoins des référendes
qui sont là et et ça s'organise autour
on va dire de plusieurs ateliers au
cours de la journée auprès auprès des
patients ou des familles ou ou des
enfants aussi en visite squeeze n'est
pas la seule pensionnaire à quatre
pattes de l'unité de soins palliatifs
Kitty a également sa place chez les
soignants l'ancienne pensionnaire de
l'ASPA de Moré a trouvé ici des
collègues de gratouille à toute heure du
jour et de la
nuit y